well speaking of chaos law enforcement
has been suspended at our southern
border which is wide open as a result
last month alone u.s officials reported
nearly 200 000 illegal migrants at the
borders those are the ones they
encountered by comparison at the end of
2020 migrant encounters total just 72
000 per month now some of these people
are using military-style camouflage to
enter the country which is bizarre
fox's matt finn has that story for us
tonight hey matt
hey tucker we've seen illegal migrants
use all types of methods to disguise or
camouflage themselves now new pictures
appear to show suspected illegal
migrants wearing ghillie suits to blend
into the desert border patrol agents in
the el paso sector arrested the three
migrants in southern new mexico ghillie
is a type of camouflage material used to
blend into various natural environments
military personnel police and hunters
use them fox news has reached out to the
u.s customs and border protection for
more information on those pictures and
these arrests come as this week the
federal government announced there were
199
000 migrant encounters at the border in
july for comparison at the end of 2020
migrant encounters were around 72 000
per month now skyrocketing to nearly 200
000 last month bringing the total number
of encounters to a record 1.94 million
this fiscal year but sources tell fox
news that number is now over 2 million
the bonded administration claims the
number of encounters is inflated under
title 42 expulsions where migrants
quickly cross back into the u.s after
being expelled under that covet-19 order
and as we have been reporting states
like texas and arizona are now moving
migrants to other states in cities like
washington d.c and new york as a former
protest to the federal government tucker
matt finn thanks so much for that
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight